hello and welcome to the new review a
source for everything anime and manga
mostly hunter hunter i do admit
and on that note more specifically
welcome to the encyclopedia where today
we are going to be exploring the varied
and new instabilities of
one kilowatt zoldic alright so as the
best boy of hunter hunter we should all
be quite familiar with kilauea who is
quite frankly one of the most talented
nen users in the entire series
continuously just snowballing within the
art form and it's incredible to look
back at just how far he's come in such a
ridiculously short amount of time before
getting into
all of that though one thing we do
really need as context for this
discussion is his background and family
life
as a member of the zoldic family who are
the world's most famous celebrity
assassins kilauea has been more or less
molded to be a perfect name candidate
right from birth mostly through a lot
of heavily abusive assassin training
although honestly the biggest tragedy of
killer's childhood was that his parents
would not allow him to press the
subscribe button for the new world of
view thus not allowing killer to receive
regular hunt hunter content uploaded
straight into his youtube bead so you
should all be thinking yourselves quite
lucky that you can quite comfortably
press that button right now
but back to some form of seriousness
before i use the word abuse however i
think the more accurate term would be
torture so for example kilauea was
exposed to many harmful substances
repeatedly
in order to build a resistance to them
such as poisons and electricity and
that's quite highly unlikely to be the
full extent of it however these
experiences would prove to be of great
benefit to kilowatt's nunn development
so kilowatt steps into the series in a
very similar position to that of gone
in terms of raw end talent he is every
bit as polished to pajamas gone and
killer's aptitude for nen has been
described as one in 10 million
just as with mr gone actually and this
is demonstrable at every turn in the
series not only is killua comfortably
able to keep up with gone learning the
basic and even advanced principles of
nan with relative ease but in fact on
many occasions kilowatt quite clearly
surpasses gone because he tends to be a
much faster learner all of which can
once again be attributed to his
upbringing which has left kilauea with
an exceptionally analytical mind capable
of being able to break down
in theory in a way that gone could only
dream of and if i had to compare the two
i would say that killua
is the great talent due to that ability
and while the argument could be made
that gone can perhaps bridge this gap
with his stunning quantity of aura that
sort of brute force approach really
isn't favored in the net art form so
killer is equipped by default with the
physical and mental tools that he needs
to truly succeed here which leads into
his affinity of transmutation
transmutation being the practice of
converting one's aura into a substance
of the user's choosing or more
accurately to mimic the properties of a
substance
this is one of if not the most versatile
in an affinity to be granted and it's
actually an inherited zeldik family
trait as all of the whitehead members of
the family are transmuters meanwhile the
blackhead members are all manipulators
and in the case of old bold maha
well his lack of hair makes him an
enhancer apparently in any case this is
where kilowatt's tragic upbringing truly
shines because the substance he would
choose to mimic through transmutation
would be electricity something he was
rather intimately familiar with due to
all of the electrical torture he
sustained and while this might seem
fairly basic at face value according to
biski being able to successfully create
an element like this at killer's age is
a fairly astonishing feat and
furthermore so is killer's innate
control of it as the electricity is
obviously one of the more unruly
substances this control actually goes so
far that in many cases kilowatt has been
shown capable of varying the damage
dealt by this electricity which can
range from mild stinging to a full on
electrocution and burns depending on mr
killer's desires
however as with all nen related things
this kind of potency and control does
come at a great cost firstly the amount
of aura kilwa requires to transmute and
discharge into electricity is immense
and in many ways out of killer's control
meaning that he is liable to run out of
aura at rather inconvenient times and
completely without warning in addition
to this kilowatt has another activation
requirement which is that he generally
needs to quote unquote
charge himself before engaging in this
brand of oral use which basically means
allowing electricity
to run through his body which can be
achieved through various means such as
tasing himself or even holding a live
wire and at this stage it's difficult to
say if this practice just makes killer's
transmutation easier because he has the
feeling of electricity to work with or
if this is a subconscious nan
restriction that he has placed on
himself to create the incredible power
he does and it could also very much be
both because
nen is pretty fun like that but with all
of this in mind killer's use of nana is
actually far less versatile than one
would initially think it would be a
pretty major mistake to consider killua
in the same sort of vein as your typical
electricity or lightning wielders in
anime and manga many of whom just seem
to completely embody their element and
if they do have limits they're quite
extreme
in comparison kilowatt is forced to
think much more tactically
about when and how to use his abilities
because any mistake made on his part is
going to have a significantly negative
effect
on his aura reserves and in that way
it's not so different from how gone uses
his aura actually
concentrating mass quantities into one
gigantic attack which if it fails
leaves him in a pretty abysmal position
and no killer isn't quite that bad
because he's much more careful about
maintaining oral reserves which results
in attacks like lightning palm for
example which is a simple palm strike
infused with electricity upon impact and
then swiftly deactivated thus providing
a sharp potent attack at minimal cost
although something like this is
generally not enough to deal with
stronger opponents especially nen users
so kilauea does need to push a little
further in that regard
and that would bring us to thunderbolt
an ability that is fairly
self-explanatory but it sees killer will
leap into the air above an opponent and
call down a powerful bolt of lightning
to strike said opponent this has
problems as well though because whilst
this might seem like quite the deadly
strike it's actually surprisingly weak
and its primary use is for stunning
opponents rather than dealing any damage
to them and to be fair it was quite
successful in stunning yupi a chimera
ant royal guard so we should not dismiss
that ability at all on the other hand it
was also unable to really inflict any
damage on remote
even before he became an end user so the
great advantage of thunderbolt is to
allow an ally of killer to attack the
opponent while stunned which was indeed
very effective as shown with gone
in the remote situation and this
actually brings up something very
important
which is that while this series is
designed to examine the individual's use
of nen
on many occasions that use is going to
be supplementary to someone or something
else
and while it might be quite tempting to
think of kilauea as someone who has
developed abilities to become a core
combatant in reality most of what he
does
is catered towards assisting others
specifically gone but also alako of
course
much of killua's development in nen is
done parallel to gon with killua
studying his friend and carefully
catering his hatsu to augment gonz
and that's one reason why kilauea's
nenus is not at all damage focused
because that's pretty much the only
thing that gonz nen tends to focus on
and in addition to that if kilowatt does
need to cause serious damage or even a
bit of the old death then he tends to
rely on his assassin skills using nen to
stun
confuse disarm trick whatever whilst he
engages in his prior mastery of the art
of killing
now to continue along this path kilowatt
does have at least one way of attaining
more control over his electrical
transmutation which is through the
vessel of delightful yo-yos
delightful yo-yos made from a custom
ally that weigh 50 kilograms each so
that's about 110 pounds per yoyo for all
the pounding people
out there assumedly made four kilowatt
by milliki now this might also be a
simple case of the yoyos taken quite
nicely to transmuted electricity but
here it's also good to note that
kilowatt may be invoking another
nanofinity such as enhancement to imbue
the yoyos with already transmuted aura
or to enhance the yoyos with aura and
then transmute the aura either way
it would work there's no real evidence
to confirm this one way or the other but
during greed island killua did engage in
extensive training in both enhancement
and conjuration which would obviously be
killer's neighboring affinities on the
nenring so he really is far more skilled
than i think even the average fan would
give him credit for although with that
in mind
to be fair all of killer's signature
abilities are attributed as being pure
transmutation
which brings us to the summit of
killer's nenus being the godspeed hatsu
now rather than a more outward use of
electricity that we've examined thus far
this is far more of an internal
application that exhibits itself in two
subforms the first of which being
whirlwind now the general idea is that
in this form killua is programming his
aura to send electrical signals directly
to his muscles
essentially trying and succeeding to
bypass the nervous system when
responding to stimuli and thus
attaining much faster reflex actions and
in the most basic of basic examples
let's say that you touch something hot
at that point the receptors in your hand
need to send signals to the brain which
then needs to send a signal to whatever
part of your body needs to produce a
reflexive response which would usually
be
take your hand off the hot thing you
idiot meanwhile with whirlwind killer
gets to skip this middle step altogether
instead now when his aura encounters the
stimuli the aura itself will immediately
send the right reactionary response
directly to killer's muscles and in
super super basic terms this gives
killua access to speed and agility that
is only surpassed by the truly godlike
figures of the hunt hunter world
however as always there is balance to be
maintained being that whilst using
whirlwind
killer is obviously not in control of
any of his functions it's kind of like
charnock's autopilot where killer just
flicks the switch and hope that
everything
turns out for the best which speaking of
there is a striking similarity between
whirlwind and charnock's autopilot and
it brings up the potential of kilawa
perhaps invoking manipulation
specifically in regards to
pre-programming his aura that is
something that should not theoretically
be available to killer through
transmutation
enhancement or conjuration however
manipulation would of course be killer's
weakest affinity which isn't to say that
he's definitely not using it it would
just make him all the more impressive if
this was indeed the case but for some
more control there is indeed a secondary
application of god speed which is known
as speed of lightning and it more or
less has the same explanation as
whirlwind except that killer maintains
his executive functions and it is not up
to the pre-programmed dora as a result
though speed of lightning is
significantly slower than whirlwind
which is
strange to say because this does give
kilowatt access to truly superhuman
speed allowing him to traverse over 40
kilometers or just under 25 miles in
roughly
10 minutes which is pretty fast but just
as with everything else both
applications of godspeed rapidly deplete
killer wazora especially the much more
intensive whirlwind function and killua
actually found himself running out of
horror when he was facing off against
yupi during the chimera ant arc now this
is notably not the full extent of
killer's abilities although this is the
end of what can be solidly attributed to
nenu's skillaware does have a greater
skill set though having
already been a fully trained assassin at
the dawn of hunter hunter and whilst i
don't see this too often there has been
some confusion about his expanded
abilities particularly that of rhythm
echo which is a technique killawa uses
that results in crafting a series of
after images of different cadence
in order to confuse and intimidate
enemies however kilauea did not know nen
when he demonstrated this indicating
that he is simply taking human actions
to the absolute extreme however in the
anime especially
it is depicted in a very similar manner
to that of the nen user with all of the
purple hues and everything
kilowatt also has another particularly
curious ability though which allows him
to immediately transform his fingernails
into claws that are as sharp as knives
and once again he could do this prior to
discovering then which
kind of boggles the mind a bit because
this can be explained quite simply as
using
really basic enhancement and many other
enhancers in the series do have similar
techniques
a lot of this is probably just due to
the nature of early hunt hunt though
as i've explored elsewhere at great
length hunter hunter is certainly not a
planned series and togashi employs an
almost whimsical style of authorship
which comes with great advantages but
also a lot of lingering oddities like
this
and a fair few outright plot holes i
mean stuff like this can also be
explained as being a subconscious use of
none which is how most humans in this
world do access their aura so kilauea
could just be employing nenu's
instinctively without a core
understanding of what he's doing but
that is very speculative
as for what we can take as fact killua
is a shockingly talented nin wielder who
in under two years pursued the art form
to a level that would be unachievable in
an entire lifetime for the average user
and i suppose the greatest thing is that
unlike gone killer still retains the
ability to go even further
and whilst we may never see this
eventuality that makes him quite a
terrifying prospect for the future
of the zoldic household but what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
in the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt hunter content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt hunter glory
delivered straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review and i'll
see you next time